is there any like dark arts kind of
involved out there with auctioning like
where people are like
putting products up there like any kind
of dirty business that kind of comes
through that you're able to see that you
keep an eye on or anything that's
happened over the years not that you
guys are pushing
yeah there's bad apples in every bit
yeah there's of course i've seen a lot
of stuff there's some
janky stuff i i've seen people break
hood hood
release and and dump ice down in the
dash to make it look cold air was called
damn put a a radio
uh picture of a radio where in the hole
where the hole is
and sell it so that you know when you're
looking through the window it looks all
good it looks like the radio is there it
was a picture of a radio
dang and you get it it's just yeah
there's some shade there's some shady
stuff going on every once in a while
yeah
for sure i could see that man i could
see that i'm trying to feel like uh
you know there's there's dealers that
will go out and
you know unplug some stuff you know
unhook a spark plug so where it comes in
it's
running rough and you know and they'll
buy it whoever buys it you should yeah
usually whoever's the one bidding hot
and heavy on it is the guy that did it
that's awesome is there discrepancies
down there in there oh that's a big
pistol in the range
yeah very much so we're always bumping
chests talking trash
i've seen one car dealer get mad at
another one and
the one the had a flashlight you know
the big mag lights you know and then
this guy was gonna beat the out of
him with his flashlight and
the other dealer he took the flashlight
away from the guy and beat the out
of him
i've also seen another auctioneer get
upset with a dealer
and uh i didn't actually see it i wasn't
there but
it's been a well-known story for years
and years and and
car dealer flipped the auctioneer off
and the auctioneer came off the block
that's a fight by the time he got down
there the guy had a knife and put it to
his throat and said come on big boy
it's like i'm backing up now i'm going
back up to my block yeah yeah
wow i mean it used to get pretty western
you know
back in the day i'm sure but now there's
cameras in everything everywhere and
everybody's calmed down now
that's much calmer much calmer yeah you
kind of missed that road you know when
it was a little bit of a rockier road
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one